welcome back to another episode of true
news boxing edition stop my chaos I love
and Paul's press conference great to be
involved yeah anyway we can't even if
we're just watching at home on YouTube
it's still involvement in a way that is
involved yeah you can't take that away
from us what about that hey Stacy
roll the clips
[Music]
those you've been living under a rock
this is ksi versus Logan Paul one of the
polls any of the polls an African I set
that up you said before this fight you
had something planned you said you
wanted to call someone else
who was the one who saw of godfather
they all of this to happen
you're looking at The Godfather Thank
You Liam from Opie Talent and here we
are downtown la behind me the Staples
Center which will be sold out on
November 9th November 8th rather for the
big fight now the dates first date
everyone saying you said it was today
yeah shoot the [__] said it yeah no
sorry she's not a [__] I'm joking she's
a perfectly good percent done yeah well
made one little mistake
I'm not criticizing her Wow let's take a
look at the Twitter poll who you got who
you got in this fight she just became a
man in New York and above oh you got my
crown do I amuse you how the [__] am i
funny like that basket bullsh I know you
never got the good one like that all
yours are [__] right seven what's going
on my friend how are you feeling right
now
fine now when you get someone who you go
get someone who knows about YouTube
neither of these people know about you
thank you going so it's a big big fight
we're gonna tick you two boxes and we're
gonna talk about them with two people
who've never watched their channels in
their god damn light not great [__] true
Jory over though this summon code comes
of it is a big big fight maybe not to
some boxer fans but sort of people in
the world this is a big fight listen to
the people in the world this is a big
fire because people outside the world
they don't give a [__]
aliens are suck they're going you and I
both know this feeling when you're on a
live camera and the other person is sort
of taught themselves not you but you
know that and you're just like throwing
them a rope like all on this I'll get
you out she throws no rope she's just
staring at the camera one this let this
[__] go 10 seconds back and just
watch if she just does not help him
happy at this point
right her face twisted so much when he
maybe not to boxing fans if you guys
don't know software on desorbed yeah
[__] this you were close in age close
hi Closen wait in your opinion who's
going to have the edge yeah um they
weigh the same amount so you better find
out that night
oh my god oh my god no I don't want to
be
I genuinely don't want to be a [__] for
the sake of it but this is just
impossible if this was you and I on the
livestream we might be getting a million
to me and when who's gonna win and I
went by the way the same amount you
people home be going this [__] [__]
doesn't know anything about boxing this
guy doesn't know what he's talking about
ultimately the one thing we can't
dispute is he's right the person who's
about a fight or night will win yes all
credit analysis there yeah yeah so last
year that first fight in front of the
sold-out crowd 21,000 people the
pay-per-view subscribers 1.3 million
people that's not to mention all the
people who are watching on youtube and
twitch
she's a twitch pirate at the phone they
just acknowledge the illegal stream yeah
whether you have to when it's like all
four million people playing both
fighters guaranteed a knockout what do
you think we will see you know me being
up me being a professional fighter and
myself oh we promise a lot of things
sometime we don't deliver sometimes we
promise a lot of things we'd go about
this is a great outfit producer
sometimes I just don't even show up to
the ring I'll say it I'm just gonna
chill tonight okay get the people hype
for this it just doesn't happen
he is the worst prom or guy in the
history of boxing is this guy I mean I
come from is anything okay you know
who's going to deliver for us that's our
own Katie Austin she's in the crowd it's
absolute mayhem down there by the stage
what do you got Katie she just
subscribed this is absolute mayhem tell
me Bryant is this like absolute mayhem
to you
these people are going wild oh my god
it's me I'm God I would really love them
to do this in London you know what the
man in the little [__] all they do it
they do it in Bethnal Green Town Hall
yes yeah it's a [__] I just took a piss
in a hole and this is design welcome
back guys
we don't quite know what we've just
eaten but it's feeling good down here
are we jazz guys oh [__] you man okay
cool she is Logan's biggest fan you even
made a sign for him why are you excited
to be here today I am so excited because
I know he's gonna win he's gonna whip
ksi
and he's better-looking number one
podcast no more youtuber I wish I had a
fun like that you do you everything oh
yeah don't feel like what somebody just
lists your achievements continually all
the time but I'm like sort of I could
just ring them up at any point gold
remind me what I've achieved and they
just go
you're gonna whip his 8 SS and you're
like thank you for self-censoring
and there's a look at him the man the
myth the legend the YouTube star the
sensation Logan Paul I'm a boxing fun
right I'm a YouTube fun right I can only
imagine how boxing purists of being
triggered watching this because I'm
being triggered yeah yeah they're
talking to the people watching this
stream like they're the dumbest [__]
people alive yeah I've never been part
realized so much am i no I love it
but hey guys welcome back mm-hmm yeah
y'all sittin at home there mm-hmm
yeah havin a good time love him this
guy's on holiday this guy's genuinely
just like I don't think I've ever been
as happy as this guy in my life he's
constantly having an orgasm you know it
reminds me of I genuinely thought that
it was a deep state you know the acid
state of our Kelly's face on a miniature
body this time in the rematch you know I
got the feeling is that he did get a
little love in LA but I also feel like
the zone when we're gonna need some of
you to support ksi here and they went
yeah cool man was that's real that's
real support feels real why was the down
dress like a snooker player do not have
a boy him come on he's our boy it's only
a game so I caught with a super dollar
dancing with a star now an awkward
standoff while Eddie herm where's his
boat shoes I really enjoyed this rivalry
by the way I really enjoy it
how can we only hear Shannon Briggs
unless you know how it loud ears yes
he's a green na now he's a disagree yes
yes no no the thing is now this is so
much more personal because they been in
there with each other hate each other
they felt each other's punches before
they've got a real idea of what they're
in for this time and it's gonna be
interesting how they respond to that in
terms of training for the fight who's
gonna take it more personally that they
drew and who really can't live with that
oh I like a side reaction that looks
great yeah is good luck it has in great
shape right now first time around I
tried not to like this I tried not to be
involved I saw a sold-out arena
I saw 1.3 million pay-per-view buy then
I saw down the side the bloody great
commentary yeah but this time I said a
few changes
yeah noir shipment yeah no [__] yeah but
not to the commentary CC no head guards
ten ounce gloves a real fight and I
promise you this time someone is getting
knocked out there will be concussion
Eddie Hearn gives us absolutes one of
these two guys will almost be fatally
injured as the guy said beforehand
sometimes don't deliver on the promises
so but he promises you what's happening
here well I think someone said something
between the two Shannon sort of got a
bit offended and then we found out that
Jake Paul dresses for urban combat good
it's like when you're talking to your
grandma on the phone your mum goes I'm
gonna pass you over right now if she is
[Laughter]
two-time heavyweight champion of the
world a Logan Paul's trainer Shannon the
cannon Brooks Logan Paul's trainer now
apparently Wow
brilliant dissing champ we gonna be in
phenomenal shape it was Logan's first
fight and guess what overwhelming tell
him what was going through his mind so
it was really bad it was awful I
remember he had a panic attack backstage
I didn't think II was gonna go out we
had to convince him to go out but
eventually did alright it was not bad
thousands of people he was mentally not
all there if I'm completely unfair afire
pisses puns yeah we mopped it up it was
fired
I was I was mopping the piss I was
shouting let's go champ and it was a big
moment for me in my life okay cool let's
go Jack
okay the last fight was will organs
first fight in the first fight is always
gonna be the most nervous
you've never done this before you had
anxiety the second fight there's no
doubt Logan it's gonna be better this is
just not he's had a lot of time he's
done this before is actual all facts
like the only thing anyone knows about
him in modern day is that he just calls
her I'm shouting next your chump in the
long jump all new boxing fans will have
no clue who he is
I'll show what video is good at which is
keep you cool in the moment yes who's
excited to see me knock this [__] out
on November 19 yeah I think so last
night I remember you were hitting your
mom on Christmas and you got kicked out
of the house for that I don't think he
hit her not true but Logan's doing the
right thing and trying to push as many
buttons as he can you get what he's
doing I seen you hit your mum mr. and
mrs. ksi thank you I [__] love you
for giving me the opportunity to beat
the [__] out of your [__] son that's
a good lighting to be failing that is a
powerful light your own [__] brother
say I'm gonna win this fight and by the
way you know who else said I'm gonna win
this fight the best boxer from your
country Tyson Fury said I'm gonna win
this fight Wow
actually kind of true Tyson Fury did
actually predict Logan Irwin actually
funky logan paul tyson i'm pretty
furious at that believes in you goober
slash boxing coach
badal what the [__] do you do take your
[__] cry-baby man yo talk to me this
is descended very quickly hasn't it I
must admit it's very hard being on stage
when it gets like this I imagine Eddie's
sort of thinking I immediately recovered
yes I have any second
how much okay oh yeah I'll just play
with it I'll bear with it no only that
but Eddie went there was such nice boys
off stage signing the contracts I'm not
getting true Geordie to take the fall in
London the idea of your breath smells
you know I'd ask that be fair I think I
came on the lot when I was six years old
if anyone's claiming it right the
[__] coyote pool that was you just
rumoured hey there Jay if you don't know
Logan's dog got eaten by a coyote n' and
he was called khan and Jaejoong what
Hong Kong sorry he even cook on it was
named after our cabinet and he's
suggesting that he will eat him oh
that's good this is good though alright
okay so this is I think they won one now
in terms of really harsh digs yeah I'm
gonna eat your dog that's a really good
line that's a really good 2 1 G 2 1 and
I'm not even
this isn't bias it's just true 2 1
Logan's started one meal with the family
yeah then ginger comes like with your
dog died yeah and now he's saying and
you oughta console anything oh but I can
what's your Excuse what's your Excuse ok
so first of all you look like you're
running up your ass and there's no
there's nothing wrong with that all
right JJ in the last Elliott press
conference was a bit
I think nervous is a new place we're
seeing him just oozing confidence yeah
and he's winning this battle it's chip
will fighting anyone on this card or not
I hope he fights nice on game I would
actually love that we love kibble he's
just how is one of the lads a great guy
he's just a good person to be around you
always feel like you should box the [__]
out of someone who loves him but I think
that would be a really competitive and
good fight yeah some people think it
would run through Jake I think Jake's
actually getting better I think it'd be
a good fight JJ has no dick JJ has no
dick Logan's mother singing along Jasha
Bob Rowe people are saying you don't
have a dick out there oh hey your mom's
right there no good good response oh
this is how's my dick no there's not one
of the options for answering here this
is the cringy bit it's we're getting
really cringey now isn't it do me a
favor
these next 55 days are gonna be the best
days of your life Oh take a break stop
training seriously get up your life yeah
after November now I'll be miserable I
kind of like the way he's going with
that that's kind of good thing they'd go
down like you think cuz your plan in
swimming in someone's head right you
know you're saying like when this day
comes that's it for you you like I like
that week a live review there of what
was happening there Logan Paul reacts to
Logan Paul to press convey this was week
what's this beep this is the weirdest be
ever it reminds me of when in joella's
last music video he was not seen like
like that like just do with me do you
know this very Joella isn't it
no touching right now no touching wait
for it they're still John tap tap tap
tap tap tap power power power and then
wow look at that tiny dick
stole the show Oh junk away Iran okay I
love it yes
he's he's taking it very serious for
hours a day six days a week that's a lot
of training how does that compare to
your training regimen Oh a tree about
five six hours a day five six so much
chew chewing doesn't bus training pop
how many times they do training ten
times ten times or you know Connect for
the mind you know I mean yeah you tubers
can be fighters I play fighters in the
world forest genuinely it's just like
it's like a real-life horoscope like you
could do whatever you like I'm knocking
Scott you play ping-pong no problem I
could join the army I could have a
shrimp boat I could do whatever I want
you know I love about this guy is
genuine within the broadcast he's gone I
should set up a YouTube just gonna
follow me on youtube no videos guys good
was in terms of the fight I'm completely
like this is an even fight yeah very
well-balanced fight like I'm not just
saying that for the video I genuinely
mean that but in terms of like
confidence and how would they play the
press conferences JJ's just getting
better and better really really well
yeah yeah I definitely think all his
live performances the venues that he
sold out must have really helped him
along the way
call me wrong I don't love them did
badly I think just judges so calm with
it great yeah yeah and that's not a
knock on Logan or Jake I love we had on
the whiteboard and now in what looks
like a seamless addition for DES own
true Georgie will link you to boxing
with real-life boxing
Bryan Tyson Fury how to fight Colleen
and we thought it was gonna be a pretty
normal Tyson fight against the guy who
isn't on the same level as he called it
a tune-up didn't little bit little bit I
mean he's an undefeated fighter but the
last undefeated guy he just made it look
like a pub fighter you know I mean he
didn't on the dosa yeah got caught with
a big
left hook I think it was to the eyebrow
which cut him open and the danger is at
that point the fight can be stopped
because of how bad the cut is yeah and
you lose your title lineal title which
isn't three have it so he was under
pressure Tyson Fury and he didn't really
look his normal self he wasn't as sharp
I think is avoidance of punches wasn't
really as good as I've seen it his power
he wasn't really landing shots where it
looked like was really hurting the other
guy until the last six rounds I'd say
and even still I've seen him hit harder
than that and his speed it was whirring
from a Tyson Fury right point of view
like he's got a massive fight in
February against Wilder and that is not
the fight that you want before that I
get were you saying are you saying this
is more than his dad's was also not
impressed
yeah and live on BT sport he said this
yeah I think he also said that it's the
worst
Tyson Furies ever seen Wow which from
your dad that kind of honesty but you
don't want it publicly like yeah maybe
text it yeah yeah well done on the wind
some but worst you've ever before yeah
and I didn't want to say this publicly
because I thought that would expose you
a little bit yeah just seen Eddie Hearn
I kind of let use and all that I've got
a new favorite Twitter account right out
of context Eddie heard rice true Geordie
dm's be like sex toys anal beads
religion voodoo dolls donkey talk okay
so you got a Saturday you gotta set it
up yeah you can't just when you when
you're in McDonald's with your mates and
and they can't work out what they want
to eat might you [__] your mind up what
you want silly tosspot I always think
you know if you want to get in someone's
good books going to a load of outer
context quotes from them or do your own
at the press conference the backlash
makes me horny so much stuff this is my
favorite when you girlfriend says do you
love me do you know who what youtuber
well who we know yeah it would be the
best out of context yeah Rory someone do
that
I will retweet
I swear to God Wow do that also context
Rory makeup cuz honestly even in context
it's out of context I'm loving it
absolutely absolutely yeah when your
piston about to fully open up to your
mere but the DJ drops a bummer
[Music]
yeah but I mean I want an 11 inch penis
it's not no just me
Eddie Honus had so much wild [__] in
interviews you do not and let's be
honest 99% of this is from I I felt she
touch him so relaxed they just comes up
with mud it's amazing
so that was true news about some of
boxing so I mean YouTube boxing it yeah
macho you do hit the like button and let
us know you what you want to talk about
on the next episode and we'll see you
soon thanks for watching guys we'll see
you again real soon right here entre
zone don't forget to subscribe to my
channel yeah